今
1995年に阪神淡路大震災が起きたとき
には私はまだ学生でした
自分の子供の頃から大好きだった
間違う
日本中の人が世界美しくていいよねって
言ってた神戸の街が崩れていくのをずっと
悲しくて悲しくて目をそらせずに見てい
ました
あの時
6434人の方が
この街周辺ではを桜になって
すごい胸の中でお亡くなりに行った方の
ことを思ったときに
その人たちがすごく大切にしてきた生活の
ステージだった
この街を
ちょっとでも
いいまちにするために
自分にも何かできることがあるんじゃない
かなーっ
ずっとそんなことを思っていました
時が過ぎて
東日本大震災の後に数字った時に私支援
物資出脅しているトラックの4隻に
潜り込ましてもらって仙台に行きました
初めのうちは結構自分でも役に立ったか
なっていうところもありまして
また神戸での経験がありますから
筋注の時にどういうことをしなくていけ
ないかとか何してはいけないかどこに行か
なくちゃいけないか
なんか少しずつは判断できることあるん
ですよね
でも
少しずつ緊急時から次のステージに動いて
きたときに
仙台の友達に一つ着替えたんです
頭って一体
どうやって復興したのっ
私全く
答えれなくてその時に気がついたんですね
自分の町になんとかして愛してシャイ
そんなことすごく思ってたくせに
本当は何にもしてなかったということに
そこに気がつきました
今からでも何かしなくちゃっていうふうに
思ったんですけども
こんな
一人の人間が街の発展みたいな大きな
テーマに
一体何が出来るんでしょうか
ずっとそれが頭にひっかかっていました
当時の神戸は
私が見ていたのは
なんだかすごい活躍して人たちがいっぱい
いるんだけども
みんなバラバラだなーって言う
そんな印象を受けていました
例えばビジネスの世界ですごい頑張って
いる方とものすごい近いフィールドで
まちづくりを
草の根がやってる人お互いに全く知らない
あるいは
福祉の世界の方で頑張っている方が同じ
対象者に対してサービスを提供しているの
に
教育の世界の方を全然知らない
で知らないだけだったらまだいいんです
けども
何か誤解してたり勝手にお互いに距離感を
感じてたり
そうになって
今僕は頭に対して思ったんだけどもたぶん
いろんな街で同じことが起きるんじゃない
かなというふうに思いました
だからこのバラバラを何とかすることが
それは自分にも表術ひょっとしたできるか
もしれない
そんな風に思いました
はじめに思ったのは実はこの活躍している
人たちを一堂に集めてなんかみんなでこう
次の街を考えようよっていうそんな勉強会
みたいなものをしようかなっていうふうに
思いました
まちづくり研究会みたいな
でもなんかすぐに気がついたんですけども
それぞれの人が思っている町のに女って
絶対いろいろ違うはずですし
それにぬなんとなくハードルが高くて
なんかマニアックな人ばっかり集まって
多分なんか運営する僕自体がすぐに多分
つまんなくなるなっていそういう印象を
押しました
じゃあ何ができるかな
もう一度考え直したんですけども
ある日ふっと思いついたんですね
この活躍している人たちを一人一人先生に
して抗議をしてもらっていくうちに
だんだん街の中がつながっていって
信頼関係が生まれてきたらみんなが協力し
合えるそんな街になるんじゃないかなと
しかも活躍してる人って必ず周り仲間が
たくさんいて
みんないっぺんに集めていけば多分
繋がっていくスピードも速いし
チェックを大切なポイントなんですけども
まちづくり研究会にあなた参加しませんか
という風に言って回るよりも多分
先生になってくださいってお願いする方が
僕としてもすごい安いですよね
こんな風にして神戸元町大学は終わりまし
た
皆さんソーシャルキャピタルって言葉ご
存知でしょうか
このまま日本語に無理に約束すると社会
資本というふうになります
社会資本体
インフラストラクチャーのこととやっぱり
区別がつかないので社会関係資本
そういうふうに日本語にすることが一般的
です
信頼し合っている人々がそこでつながって
いると
何かアクションを起こすときにすごく重要
な資源になるよねっ
そういう考え方です
今日いらっしゃっているみなさんも
お互いに話し合って少しわかったっていう
今の状態からこの会場全体がみんなで信頼
関係を持てるようにまでこの回が終わる
までもしなったら
23時間後にここに大災害が起こっても
あるいはみんなで何かしようっていうふう
にこうみんなで考えてもですねたぶん
すごい力なりますよね
ソーシャルキャピタルってそういう
シンプルな考え方です
ソーシャルキャピタルには3つのタイプが
あります
左上にありますけれども
いったいどんだけ有力な人とどれだけ
つながっているんだろうという人脈とか
ネットワーキングのようなもの
二つ目が
まあクラブとかあるいは団体会社の中
みたいな借りられた閉ざされた空間の中で
どれだけの人が信頼関係が結ばれているか
そういう観点ですで
私が関心あるのはこの3つめのもの
地域社会全体に信頼が広く浸透していて
直接目の前の人のことは
あんまり知らない人だったとしてもなんと
なくこの地域の人だから信頼できるな
そういう感覚があったらこれは共有財産と
してのソーシャルキャピタルがあるそう
いうことになります
これは今地域の社会を発展させていくため
の基盤として大変注目を集めています
おすごい注目を集めているくせに
すごく残念なことなんですけどもこれどう
やってこれをつくったらいいかその方法論
はどんな本読んでも書いてないんですよね
でもひょっとしたら私が偶然神戸元町大学
出始めていることがその方法論の1つに
なるかもしれない
そんな風に今思っています
神戸元町大学でやっていることはすごい
簡単で
同じ地域の中で活躍している人を先生にし
て読んでだいたい月に2回ぐらい抗議をし
ているそんなスタイルです
私たちはもともとこの分野だけをやるんだ
っていうソジャンルがありませんので待ち
中の老若男女有名な方もそうでもない方も
それからあがいる分野の方も先生として
およびできるそんな可能性があります
そんな特徴を使って私は神戸の街の人たち
をつなげていけたらというふうに思ってる
んですね
レアの
全くお金の匂いがしないそんな集まりです
のでやっぱり9純正に向上心がある人
ばかりが集まっています
しかも一つ一つの講義のテーマにそこに
関心があって集まってきた若い人ばかり
ですから
お互いに信頼感をつくっていくその
スピードが本当に早いになって実感してい
ます
このようにあの
やっていること自体はすごいシンプルなん
ですけれども実は講義自体が目的ではなく
てソーシャルキャピタルを作るをそんな
目的があるために私たちは5つのことに
いつも式を向けて運営しています
一つ目は遠くからつなぐということです
この絵でいうとこの左下の子繋がってる
とこじゃなくて
もっと右上の方の遠いところがつないで
いくそんなイメージですね
私自身の身の回りにもすごい高面白いこと
を研究してたりトライしてる人がいて多分
話も面白いだろうなというふうにそんな風
に思う方先生にふさわしい方いっぱいいる
んですけどももうのすごい失礼ながらそう
いう方は先生としてお招きしたことがあり
ません
いつも講師の候補が私の手元に来くるたび
にですね
フェイスブックもこの強かった開いて一体
共通の友達何人ぐらいいるんだよってみる
んですけども数十人は数百人共通の友達が
いる方には興収は生まれ講師としてお招き
しないんですね
もうすでにつながっていますし
そんな形よりも本当になんとなく面白そう
なことをしてるんだけども
今日山と街が一人とか二人しかいないと
そんな方と一緒につながっお話を聞いて
つながる方がまちじゅうが繋がっていく
スピードはものすごく速いなというふうに
感じています
二つ目が無理に集めないということです
あらゆるイベントそうだと思うんですけど
もやっぱり一生懸命企画したらたくさんの
人に集まってきてほしいな
そういうふうに願いますよね
ねそのためにちょっと楽しそうな近くを
沢山おりますで見たりあるいは有名な方を
選んでみたりあるいは
友達中に連絡をして地点落ちてよという風
に行ったり
神戸元町大学リアそういうことを
避けています
むしろ講師やテーマの素直に見た時の
ありのままの魅力が伝わって行ったほうが
そこに集まってきた方々は絶対に
テンションが高く集めてくれるください
ますしお互いに共感を感じるものすごい
速いなというふうに考えています
たくさん繋がりたくなるのは当たり前なん
ですけどもそのためには丁寧に小さい
集まりを何度も何度もしていることその方
が大事だなというふうに思っています
3つ目だ
そうやってなんとかハードルを乗り越えて
集まってきた方が目の前にしたら今度は逆
のお話なんですけども無理につなげていく
ということですね
無理にでもつながるようなチャンスを作ら
ないとやっぱり初めての方に自己紹介し
たり自分もこんなことしたいんだって話を
するのは凄い心理的に抵抗ありますよね
私自身も
セミナー中に参加した時に隣の人に自己
紹介とかも絶対しないタイプです
ですから
プログラムの中でなんとかドライの方が
自己紹介したりお互いの共通の関心ごとお
話をしていくそんな時間を取らないと
せっかく同じテーマに食らいついて貴重な
時間を割いて集まってきた方々に申し訳
ないなというふうに思います
だから
自己紹介しましたいっていうとはチェック
はそうは言っても皆さん嫌そうな顔され
たり
scene in てしたりすることある
んですけども
もう本当に集まっていただいた方々に何と
か一つでも多くのつながりをつくって
いただきたいそんな思いで皆さんのいや
そうな思いをいつも乗り越えています
次にですねせっかく集まって楽しんで
下さったそんな方に対してもできる限り
リピーターにはならないで下さいっそんな
ことをお願いしています
今言い方としてはですね
次にも c ものすごく関心があるテーマ
があったらその時にぜひお越しください
ない
まあそんな言い方をしたりするんですけど
も
まあそもそも何かリピーターの方が常に高
一定数いるようにの場所っていうのは奥
自身結構1にくいんですよねなんかこう皆
さんお顔見知りでなんかこう
すごい今日のテーマに関心があるかという
とむしろそうではなくてずっと来てますの
でそういう場になってしまうと人と人が
つながる力って言うのは私は失われていく
というふうに思うんですね
だからスタッフに対しても失礼かなと思い
ながらも
皆さんスタッフだけども関心が無かったら
そのテーマ時は来ない方がいいですよって
いうだかそんなことまでお願いしています
みんなが外交家が良くていつも同じような
人ばっかり着ているそんな場には人と人を
つなぐ力はないな
そんな風に考えています
最後に
私たち自身が大きなコミュニティの中心に
はならない
にそれもすごく気にしています
なんだかこう
度かに中心がいつもあってっていうか中心
がどこにあるがなんとなくわかってその
中心にいつも情報が集まっているようなと
ころって何か私結構違和感あるんですよね
そんなことよりも
集まってくれた人々がみんないろんな
つながりを持っていて羽生になっていて
その成果でいろんな多種多様な試行錯誤が
待ち中で生まれている方が絶対地域に対し
てインパクトあるじゃないですか
だから
実は神戸元町大学で出会った人たちが私や
スタッフでを全然知らないところで
プロジェクトを始めていて
あとでや実は結構成功しかけてるんだけど
もこんなプロジェクトを始めているんです
よってそんなふうに教えてくる時に私は
本当に嬉しいなって思います
今からそんな事例はいくつかご紹介します
この左の方は
認知症などの改善のために医療とアートの
垣根を越えて作られた臨床美術という
まあそういう分野の講師として元町大学で
お話をしてくださいました
私自身もワークショップの中で数週年ぶり
に絵を書いたんですけども本当に心を開け
てくれるようなそれでいて完成
モチベーションもすごく花開くような
素晴らしい体験をしました
右な方はその講義を受けてくださった看護
師の方です
講義の中で臨床美術の力をすごい感じて今
ではほかの多くの方と一緒にパートの力で
地域を輝かせたいそんな活動を一生懸命さ
れています
こちらの右の方は消防したんですけども
普通に pr するだけで本当に防災意識
って高まるんだろうか
何か他に方法ないのかなってことをずっと
考えているそんな方でした
左の方は地域の老舗の食品会社の方です
この二人は出会ってすぐに意気投合して
この手に持っておられる
レトルトのカレーを商品化されました
このカレーは面白くて消防学校で馴染まれ
ている
消防学校のレストランのカレーの味を再現
しながらパッケージすごく風されていて
防災意識を高められるあるいは
ちゃんと庫を備えて備蓄しなくてはいけ
ないそんな気持ちを高めていくような工夫
がされていますもちろんこの商品自体も
備蓄ような食費として置いておけるそんな
複合的な意味を持っています
この2人はこのプロジェクトを通して異
業種の人が集まって何かをしていくと防災
市獅子意識みたいなものすごく硬くて
誰もが難しく感じていたそんなテーマも一
つ上のステージに持っていける
そんなことを体験されました
考えてみたら
自分1人で街のために一体何ができるん
だろうって悩んだところから
あっそうなんだ
ソーシャルキャピタル
そこに専念してみようそういうふうに思っ
ていまではその場で出会った方々が
いろんなプロジェクト花開かせてくださっ
ています
私自身が何かしたわけではないんですけど
も
プラットフォームにてすることで
街の輝きを取り戻していくそんな入り口に
立てたのかなというふうに今では思ってい
ます
今日私はソーシャルキャピタル
これをキーワードにしてそれをつくって
いくために5つの方法論を見出しました
そんなことを報告しました
一つ目は遠くからつなぐことそして無理に
集めないこと
そして参加してくださった方にはちょっと
無理をお願いしてでも繋がっていく
チャンスを作っていくこと
リピートを求めないこと
私たち自身が中心になるのではなくて
むしろたくさんの羽生ができるような
そんな関係性をつくっていくこと
ソーシャルキャピタルをつくっていくため
に
別に
地域に学びの場を作っていく必要はあり
ませんし
この五つ以外にもたくさん方法論をある
そんなふうに思います
でも最後に振り返ってみたいんですけども
これ
何一つ
難しいところがないんですよねむしろ全部
すごく簡単で
でも
全部がですねショットずつ人の自然な感覚
とは違う不自然だものが多いなそんな印象
が私にはあります
人は
家族とか半ばとか
そこと外側の間に線を引きます
でその線の内側と外側を区別していく
だから人に自然な感性のまま動いてもらう
と
水が低い所に流れていくようにどうしても
小さな
居心地のいいコミュニティの輪を作って
その中に閉じこもってしまいます
私自身も全く例外ではありません
だからこそ
地域中に信頼の絆を広げていきたい
ソーシャルキャピタルを広げていきたい
そんなことを願った時には
少し自分の自然な感覚実は逆らって
意識してコミュニティとコミュニティの
境界を崩してそれをつないでいくそんな
ことが必要だなというふうに感じています
自然にできた教会を
意識して乗り越える
そうすることで町は抱えていくと私は信じ
ています
皆さんの参考になれば幸いです本日は本当
にありがとうございました